В ефірі «heute journal».
Доброго вечора.
Канцлер Шольц та Еммануель Макрон
відновили полілог з Володимиром Путіним.
Після оприлюднення фрагментів
телефонної розмови
можна сказати, що настрої не змінилися.
Путін попередив про подальше
постачання зброї
та про те, що експорт зерна з України
неможливий,
допоки не пом'якшають санкції проти Росії.
Хліб для світу як «розмінна монета», так би мовити.
Тим часом російським військам на Донбасі,
очевидно, вдалось захопити ще одне місто.
Домінік Лесмайстер з коротким оглядом
поточної ситуації на фронті.
Це світлини зруйнованих місць.
Супутникові знімки американської компанії «Maxar»
показали  воєнний фронт на Сході України.
Війська РФ масово атакують позиції
українських захисників на Донбасі.
Президент України Зеленський назвав
становище «дуже складним».
На Донбасі зосередили максимум артилерії
та резервів.
Ракетні удари, авіаудари - все.
Нависає загроза оточення міст Сєвєродонецьк
та Лисичанськ.
Лиман на Півночі майже захопили, як і Попасну
на Півдні.
Досі тримається лише Бахмут.
Зараз мова йде про евакуацію мирних
жителів: літніх, хворих.
Лінія фронту знаходиться всього за кілька
кілометрів.
Ми їдемо до родичів, але повернемось сюди,
як ситуація стане кращою і буде тихо.
Губернатор області
вже говорить про тактичний відступ.
У нас ще вистачить сил та ресурсів, щоб захищатися.
Попри це є можливість наказу
про відступ для того,
щоб нас не оточили.
На відео, яке оприлюднило
Міністерство оборони України,
зафіксовано застосування Росією
термобаричної зброї.
Заборонені вакуумні бомби
спричиняють великі пожежі.
Становище українських захисників на Сході країни
дедалі складніше.
Режим Володимира Путіна не єдиний у світі,
до якого потрібно застосовувати демократію.
Також і Китайська Народна Республіка -
держава, від якої
так чи інакше потрапляють в економічну залежність
і яка використовує «зміни через торгівлю»
як виправдання.
Стало очевидним, як диктатори в Пекіні
борються зі своїми критиками, стежать за людьми
та пригнічують натяки на свободу у Гонконзі.
Велика кількість документів, так званий архів
«Xinjiang papers» доводить те,
як уйгурів інтегрували в табори для перевиховання,
а також застосовували тортури.
Тож цікаво, як відреагувала Комісарка ООН з прав людини
наприкінці свого візиту до Китаю.
Ульф Роллер з репортажем.
У молодому віці Мішель Бачелет зазнала тортур.
Її сім'я була в немилості за часів диктатури
Піночета в Чилі, і вона, і її батько були ув'язнені.
Тепер вона - Комісарка ООН з прав людини
і прибула з візитом до Китаю.
Вона б хотіла розповісти про своє минуле,
але Китай не залишив можливості.
Бачелет отримала книгу про права людини,
яку написав сам президент Сі.
Вона приїхала не для просвітлення.
«Цей візит - не розслідування», - повідомляє вона.
З огляду на нові документи це висловлювання
звучить як зрада.
Вони доводять жорстокість табірної системи.
Шокувальні фотографії і велика кількість файлів
висвітлюють весь жах.
В ім’я боротьби з тероризмом
мусульманські меншини
постійно зазнають пригнічень в Сіньцзяні.
Конфісковані докази радикальних настроїв
здаються глузуванням.
Бачелет нічого про це не згадує.
Вона критикує з великою обережністю.
Я заохочую Китай
переглянути свою боротьбу з тероризмом,
щоб переконатися,
що вона підпорядковується законам про права
людини.
Китай використав візит Мішель Бечелет
в пропагандистських цілях.
На державному телебаченні все було представлено,
ніби уповноважена представниця ООН
уважно слухає президента Китаю Сі
під час того, як він вихваляє свою країну за хорошу
політику в галузі прав людини.
Мовчання Бачелет нестерпне
для членів Світового конгресу уйгурів.
У багатьох з них члени сім'ї перебувають в таборах.
Вони почуваються зрадженими.
Жінок стерилізують,
їх катують і ґвалтують у в'язницях.
А якщо хтось такого рівня навідується і нічого не каже,
я вважаю, що така людина повинна негайно
піти у відставку.
Диктатури процвітають, коли їм все сходить з рук,
це Мішель Бачелет дізналася дуже рано.
Сьогодні вона могла б наділити голосами
усіх жертв.
Однак вона промовчала.
Передаю слово Гайнцу Вольфу.
Міністр соціальних питань Гайль пропонує
додаткові фінансові пільги
з наступного року для людей з низьким і середнім
доходом
та для тих, хто отримує допомогу «Hartz 4» через
безробіття.
Кліматична субсидія виплачуватиметься особам,
чий місячний дохід менше ніж 4000 євро брутто,
а також сімейним парам з доходом менше ніж 8000
євро на двох.
Через можливу нову хвилю коронавірусу восени
очільник інституту Роберта Коха Вілер виступив за
введення заходів безпеки,
а також правову базу для їхнього регулювання.
Поточна версія закону «Про захист від інфекцій»
чинна до 23 вересня, зараз уряд
обговорює правила захисту
від коронавірусу восени.
Від сьогодні в роздрібній торгівлі діє новий
регламент зазначення цін.
Мета - полегшити споживачам
пошук необхідної інформації.
Наприклад, завдяки основній інформації про ціну за
кілограм або літр
та додатковим даним про знижку.
Футболістки команди «Вольфсбург»
здобули перемогу у фіналі Кубку Німеччини
проти потсдамського клубу «Турбіне» з рахунком 4:0.
На екрані ви можете побачити номери суботньої лотереї.
Як завжди, всі дані без гарантій.
А зараз - прогноз погоди.
Завтра буде хмарно,
дощитиме та очікуються поодинокі грози.
Вітер помірний у напрямку з півночі на північний захід.
Температура сягатиме від 11° до 18°,
це досить прохолодно.
У понеділок найбільше опадів із грозами
очікується на Півночі та на Сході,
з вівторка - переважно на Півдні.
У середу потеплішає, стовпчик термометра покаже
від 20° до 26°.
Сьогодні ввечері Каннський кінофестиваль добігає
кінця.
Кульмінацією стало вручення «Золотої пальмової
гілки» за найкращий фільм.
Цього року її виборов швед Рубен Естлунд
за свою похмуру сатиру про вище суспільство
«Трикутник смутку».
Фільм був представлений цього тижня
у випуску «heute journal».
У стрічці зіграла Іріс Бербен.
Це був ювілейний 75-й фестиваль
на Лазуровому березі.
Сабіна Шульц підсумує для нас,
яким же був фестиваль цього року.
Фестиваль різких контрастів.
Світ побачили зворушливі фільми, як-от історія міграції
від режисерів братів Дарденн, дуже близькі людському серцю.
А також абсолютно приголомшливі картини,
як-от похмуре бачення майбутнього Девіда
Кроненберга.
Том Круз рекламував другу частину «Топ Ґан: Меверік»,
а в небі відбулося справжнє
авіашоу над Каннами.
Режисери, прибулі з України, де йде
справжня війна,
не оцінили видовище.
Припиніть ґвалтувати нас!
Вони протестували всіма силами
проти зґвалтувань російською армією,
проти самої війни і проти участі російського фільму
на кінофестивалі.
Суперечності світу просочилися і до Канн.
Відчай через війну Путіна
поряд із гламуром і сексуальністю моделей у
вишуканих вбраннях.
Зірковий культ як спроба
зберегти мистецтво кіно і його майбутнє.
До 75-річчя ювелірний будинок «Chopard»
прикрасив пальмову гілку 100 діамантами.
Але образи перед кінозалом іноді
були сильнішими,
ніж історії на екрані.
На жаль, цей рік кінофестивалю не приніс багатий
врожай фільмів.
Це були всі новини дня.
Переглядайте «Today Xpress» о 0:30.
До побачення.